Hey guys,
Are you addicted to something right now?
I challenge you to be honest with yourself.
You might be addicted to something
and you don't even realize it.
So how do you know?
Well, you test yourself.
I want you to answer these
questions and answer them honestly.
Number one -
Do you crave this
thing every week or even every day, meaning
you feel that you can never get enough of it?
You always want to do it again?
Two -
Do you get irritated or
anxious when you can't do it?
Three -
Does it feel
like you need to do this thing in order to satisfy
your craving to feel better and more in control?
Four -
Is this
thing disrupting your friendships
or even your normal daily routine?
Five -
Do you tell yourself you won't do it again
but then you turn around and you do the
exact same thing over and over again?
Now if you answered yes to most of these questions
then you are probably addicted to something,
especially if you answered
yes to the last question.
You see, addiction comes from sin.
It comes from your sinful flesh.
It can get so strong that
it overpowers your own will.
It is only God's spirit that
can help you to overcome it.
Listen to Romans 7:15...
[Romans 7:15]
You know, Christians can
especially feel bad about this.
And even doubt their own salvation,
because they've been trying to
overcome this through the soul level.
Their own will, own emotions, own intellect.
And they haven't been fighting through the Spirit.
So changing from the soul level to the spiritual
level - fighting it through that - is the
key to overcome any sin and addiction.
[Romans 7:17-23]
You see, you are not the only
person who struggles with this.
Paul wrote about this 2,000 years ago, already.
And you need to understand that this sinful
condition in us human beings, it is a disease,
and you need to admit this about yourself first,
before you can overcome it.
Because the truth will set you free.
He says in Verse 21:
[Romans 7:21]
You see, it's - you need to understand
this - it's a waging war in your mind.
Making you captive.
You see, sin is poison.
And if you just leave it, it
leads and grows into addiction,
like pornography.
Jesus said:
[Matthew 5:27- 29]
So let's go with this example of pornography.
Watching porn is a sin.
God is very serious and very direct about this.
And it can turn into addiction.
It works like this: You watch a little bit,
and then a little bit more, a little bit more,
before you know it doing this
sin - this sin starts to grow.
It takes root in your mind.
More roots, roots, roots.
And it grows.
It's living in your mind.
It creates pathways like the roots of a tree.
The more you do it, the more it grows.
Actions grow into habits, then it grows so
much that it becomes part of your routine.
It is evil growing within
you, becoming an addiction.
And that is what is so important
for people to stop sin before
it starts to take root in your life.
And people who struggle with a certain
addiction for a long time, that have many
roots, many pathways already in their brain.
So all those pathways in your mind - it
disrupts your normal life, your relationships,
and every small root is like an impulse
that makes you want to do that addiction.
For example, the moment you see a girl
in a bikini on Facebook or Instagram
or even in a TV show, it immediately
makes you think about watching porn.
Now, a lot of people think that they can still
overcome it, when it is even this strong.
They can still overcome it with
their own power, their own willpower.
If you think that, I need to tell you this.
You have already lost the battle.
If you don't change right now - because
you cannot overcome it by yourself.
Because yourself is already wretched -
it has that sinful flesh in you already.
Paul says in Verse 24:
[Romans 5:24]
You see, now Paul is on the right track,
because he's saying, man, I am righteous.
He understands that and now, he's
looking outside of himself and asking,
who can deliver me From myself?
And then in Verse 25 we see the answer:
[Romans 7:25]
And directly in the next chapter,
he continues and he says:
[Romans 8:1-4]
And here it comes.
Listen closely.
[Romans 8:34]
You see, that is part of the
reason why Jesus came to Earth.
To set us free from our sin.
To give us the Holy Spirit
when we accept Him as Lord and Savior.
So that we have the power we need to overcome sin.
And that includes addiction.
Jesus said:
[John 8:34-36]
So how do we fight with the
Spirit in us- against sin?
Well, let's continue to read and
the answer will become clear.
[Romans 8:5]
So you need to set your mind
on the things of the Spirit.
You need to study the Word of God and you need
to let the Holy Spirit change your mind to be
thinking about the things of the Spirit.
Let's continue.
[Romans 8:6-7]
You see, when you want to overcome sin and
addiction through the flesh, you cannot do it.
It is impossible.
[Romans 8:8]
You see, this is why people who battle addiction
like, for example, alcohol - when they are
so tired of their addiction - regretting the
destruction it brought on their lives - they
look to God repent of their sins.
And they accept Christ into their life.
Then in a lot of cases they are
freed from their addiction as well.
We know that in psychology converting
to Christianity is a proven treatment
that works for people who are
addicted to alcohol, for example.
That is according to how they
see it - a proven treatment.
But we know the reality of it.
We know it is God that comes and changes a person.
They are ... sick and tired
of their old lifestyle.
Being addicted to alcohol, and the
destruction it caused in their lives.
And they reach out to God
and they say, God help me.
Make me free.
Save me from all the things that I've done.
I'm sorry.
I repent.
And I accept you as Lord and Savior.
Come and make me a new person and God does it.
He gives His Spirit that comes
and lives inside of them.
Helping them to overcome that addiction.
And they are freed.
[Romans 8:9]
Meaning if you truly are a reborn
Christian, God's Spirit is in you.
There are many people who say that
they are Christians, but they are not.
They're just practicing dead man's religion.
They have never been reborn.
Spiritually reborn.
And this is what he's talking about.
Let's continue.
[Romans 8:9-11]
Wow, so first you need to learn how to fight
through the Spirit, through God's power in you.
Not through your own flesh, your own will.
Your own emotions, your own intellect,
making your plans .... I've got to do this
and this... is trying to fight it on your own.
Because you will not be victorious.
You need to do it for God's spirit.
And where you start is here.
Go and clean everything inside of you.
Go and repent of all the sin that you have done.
Ask God to forgive you.
A purification needs to be done.
[1 John 1:9]
So God cleans you.
He washes you clean.
Because of His blood.
He died for your sins.
On the cross.
You accepted.
You're asking God - sorry that I drank so much -
sorry that I watch pornography - sorry that I've
let it take root in my life.
You go and you be specific.
You ask him, Father, reveal to me through the
Holy Spirit what do you want me to confess.
Bring to my mind everything that is
wrong, that is in the way of me and You,
to walk forward in righteousness.
And then you will see.
Now you remember this and then
you ask God to forgive this.
And then next is another thing, another
thing, another thing, you continue to do
that until there is nothing.
Until you are clean.
And then you move forward.
You trust His word that says
that if you ask Him for forgiveness He will
forgive you. You don't go by our feelings.
You leave the past.
Because now you've sorted it out.
You never have to think about it again.
It is done.
God declared you as righteous.
He forgave you because His word says it.
So now you also need to forgive yourself.
Remember you live now according to the
Spirit, not according to the flesh anymore.
And you also need to go back and ask
forgiveness to those that you have hurt.
Everything you do now needs
to be done through the Spirit.
[Galatians 5:16-24]
Do you see?
Jesus did not just die on the cross for you.
He wasn't just crucified for our sins.
When you accepted Him, you decided to
turn away from your old sinful lifestyle.
That old sinful lifestyle
was crucified with Jesus.
That's what it means, when you're baptized, you
died, your old self under the water, when you come
up, it symbolizes your new life in Jesus Christ.
Read this with me again.
[Galatians 5:24-25]
So, how do you keep in step with the Holy Spirit?
Well, first you need to educate yourself.
You need to renew your mind.
So you need to read scripture, the Logos,
and then as you read it, let the Holy Spirit
guide you through the Rhema word.
To talk to you through scripture.
The church - your brothers and sisters
in Christ - as you grow spiritually.
This is so important.
You need to grow into a mature Christian.
Because over time, you'll become stronger so that
you can handle the sin in your life a lot better.
You need to live in the truth.
In the Spirit.
You need to live it, act it,
breathe it, write it on your heart.
You need to obey it.
And over time you will
grow spiritually stronger with the armor
of God that you need to put on daily.
You see, God is amazing.
He doesn't leave us alone to go
through these things by ourselves.
Because we cannot.
He is there with you.
He will help you to grow spiritually, but
it is your responsibility to make time for God.
Remember, new Christians, especially, they look
like spiritual babies.
It doesn't look good.
You know, imagine a grown-up
man walking around in a diaper.
It doesn't look good.
You know, it's not supposed to be that way.
There are many people who claim to be Christians
for years but they are still spiritual babies,
and so they will always struggle.
You don't want to stay like that.
A spiritual baby.
You want to grow.
[1 Corinthians 3:1-3]
There are still a lot of people out there -
there are a lot of lukewarm Christians - who
are not really Christians at all.
But then there are a lot of Christians
who just sit at home on their
couches in their comfort positions.
They don't grow spiritually.
They are kind of stuck.
And it is so sad to see that
he couldn't stay like that.
Do not be like those people.
Grow in the Word.
Grow in truth.
Become spiritually mature.
When you read the Bible, don't
just let it be informative.
You need to act, change over
to being obedient to the Word.
You know, when you read the Bible, don't
just read and say, oh this is interesting.
This is interesting.
No, read it in this way.
Oh the Bible says I have to do
this - I have to do this - okay,
how am I going to apply this in my life?
Am I doing this?
How do you read the Bible or do you just read
it and it tells you - oh I need to tell Susan
this I need to tell John about this.
No, the Bible is talking to you.
God needs to be your first priority
and to study the Word and listen
to the Holy Spirit and obey Him.
You will always have a will on your
soul level and this is where God gives
you the freedom to choose how to live.
But you need to choose to
always let the Spirit guide you.
Let me explain it to you in a
way that you can understand.
If you go to the bathroom,
the tap - the water is there.
It's available.
But you need to open it.
And it's the same way you need to open yourself
so that the Holy Spirit can flow through you.
If you do that, if you allow the Holy Spirit to
guide you, your own emotions - your will - your
intellect - man, it's amazing.
Because He moves in righteousness,
in truth, and then you come along and your
emotions, your will, your personality,
your attitude.... starts to change.
It becomes more like Christ.
Your mind is renewed.
It's beautiful.
And if you do that, you will always
produce the fruit of the spirit:
According to Galatians 5, and this is
important, because self-control - you need
to have self-control - to do what?
To overcome sin and addiction.
Remember, God also says that He
has not given us a spirit of fear.
Don't fear this addiction or trying to fight it.
Now with the Spirit,
you have to tackle it by the horns.
God has not given us a spirit of fear
but a spirit of power, love, and self-control.
You need to act in this truth so you have the
power through Christ to overcome addiction.
Now you just need to access this power every day.
Put on the armor of God and fight it.
Because it is going to be a battle every day.
You're gonna need to battle
your own fleshly desires.
But also sometimes the devil and his demons.
[1 Peter 5:8]
For some reason, there are a lot of
Christians who are scared of the devil.
I don't understand why.
Because Jesus Christ already won on the cross.
He's victorious.
You are victorious through Jesus Christ,
meaning you have the authority to rebuke
the devil, to resist him, and he will flee.
You need to walk in this truth.
In boldness.
You pray for protection, you walk in this
truth, and the devil stands no chance.
[James 4:7]
Now, a good thing that you can do is to
replace that addiction - those habits - with
something spiritual, like every time
you want to do it, when your flesh
wants to do it, you overcome it with the Spirit.
And you go and you pray, or you read the Bible,
or you call even a friend and pray with them.
You know, I've seen many men who are totally
healed of a lot of things, even depression.
Just because they went and prayed with a brother.
And they brought everything out.
And God came and healed them.
The Bible says that you have to confess your
sins to each other so that you might be healed.
And part of that is a process - where it's
a purification process that I talked about
earlier - where you need to go and
you need to bring out everything.
If you wash dishes, you don't just
wash the outside, right, of a cup.
You wash the inside clean before you use it again.
It's the same thing.
You need to wash yourself on the inside,
and only God can do that with His blood.
To wash you as white as snow.
Go to God and you pray to Him
about all the sin that you have done, calling
them by name, forgiving what people did to you.
What you did to others, and you do
that process with the Holy Spirit.
You can do this alone as well.
You go into your bedroom door,
you close that door, where you are alone with God.
Where God sees you in secret,
and He will listen to you.
And you say, God please do your work within me.
Search my heart Lord and tell me through
your Spirit what I need to repent of.
I want to be clean.
Pure before you.
Please help me to be psychologically stable by
sorting out my past once and for all. Please bring
to my mind the things I have not yet sorted out.
If you have not done that,
then you have to do that first.
And you can do it right now after this video.
And if you want to understand better
the difference between the Spirit and
the soul then please watch this video here.
It's a little bit older from my other channel,
but it will definitely help you out.
And always remember, that life is short,
so don't waste yours.
Bye guys.